wow what a binge so I'm undeniably late
to this party for the last month or so
I've consistently seen a number of
people suggest this show on Netflix
blueeyed Samurai me being this late to
the party I imagine there's nothing I
can add to the conversation about
blueeyed Samurai but my God I just
watched it and I want to talk about it
what is blueeyed Samurai will simply put
is a Revenge fueled eight episode blood
bath and that's probably all I need to
say that's enough right you need to hear
me talk about this anymore I feel like
that is the sales pitch but I guess I
still will why algorithm baby it's an
animated series on Netflix takes place
in 17th century feudal Japan Japan at
this time has adopted a very strict
border policy only Japanese people
allowed in Japan but with any system
there are those who slip through the
cracks thus our protagonist Mizu is half
white half Japanese has blue eyes which
she hides and yes that's she not he it's
treated as a reveal at the end of the
first episode but the voice actor is
clearly a woman woman but I was like so
is Bart Simpson so we'll see could just
be a dude with a feminine voice turns
out Mizu is a woman posing as a man in
that mulong kind of way but in Japan
should get this out of the way right now
before you go you know what sounds
exciting the family and I will watch it
this weekend stop video the show is very
graphic violent yes also in terms of sex
and nudity a lot of graphic sexual one
could say debaucherous content there
were a couple scenes in particular where
I was like you just you had to didn't
you you just did but generally speaking
it's within context and character with
that out of the way the animation in
this show is absolutely gorgeous without
losing the artistic nature of it being
animation there is a realism to the
character's movements even eye movements
it was shocking I wouldn't be surprised
if they filmed this movie with motion
capture or people and then did the art
over it the action sequences are fluid
they're smooth they're well
choreographed this is where dark gritty
action fueled stories lend themselves to
animation cuz if this was was live
action you would notice all the CGI
green screen going down all of it being
animated it just looks [__]
incredible also the side characters
ranged from endearing to complex and
engaging there are truly unlikely
pairings that happen in this show like
the first one the first Ally she meets
Ringo voiced by masoka who played hero
Nakamura in the show Heroes who
essentially has that same lovable type
energy in here who has no hands which I
really appreciate a huge theme in this
entire series is one of overcoming and
growing past the hand you were dealt yes
that has to do with the faithful and
Noble companion who is very useful on
the quest who was born without hands but
also the blind sword maker who has no
eyes there's actually a conversation
between the two of them where he was
like oh you need hands to be a Samurai
and the sword maker as he is forging a
sword says and you need eyes to be a
sword maker the princess set to be
married off who refuses to have that be
her life which with her at first I was
like all right let's let's get back to
the vengeance but by the end there's
actually a really complex and fulfilling
Arc with her in her situation trying to
keep it vague cuz I don't want to it's
not a playby play for the entire show
I'm just saying point is the characters
aren't defined by their seeming
limitations or handicaps Ringo isn't
just the guy with no hands he's her
conscience that Jiminy Cricket character
the good angel on her shoulder telling
her the Paragon decision she should
probably be making the sword maker isn't
just the blind guy he's the wise Warrior
teacher and tigan isn't just the douche
childhood bully I would have been fine
with that I would have been cool if it
was like oh this childhood bully now in
adulthood we meet again bully needs to
be taught a lesson but do you want fine
or do you want great this show knows the
difference and it goes well what if
enemy becomes friendenemy and what if
Frenemy becomes one of the most complex
characters with one of the most
fulfilling arcs of growth in the entire
series and that brings us to our main
character Mizu out the gates strong
badass capable confident but also she's
a very flawed human which makes her
relatable because aren't we all but most
importantly not Invincible she's not
Invincible because there's an
understanding here that part of a
character's strength comes from how they
react to losing you don't have a
character that ever gets knocked down
the audience will never know how they
react to that thus they will never know
how strong the character actually is not
to put too fine a point on the samurai
sword analogy but there was a samurai
sword analogy I heard 20 years ago now
from a pastor he told me how in order to
forge a sword you have to heat it beat
it Smash It fold it cool it heat it beat
it against it's a very it's a very rough
process on the steel but by the end what
you have is a very strong sword he said
people are very much the same way
talking about you know trials in life to
the point it's not about being
Untouchable it's not about being
Invincible or instantly great at
everything it's about being on your
quest and when you get your ass beat to
an inch of your your life which she
definitely does a few times in here
having the conviction and fortitude to
continue the quest maybe you got to heal
up but after you're healed up you
continue the quest that's her she does
that it's just [__] awesome blue-eyed
Samurai does a good job at illustrating
that heartache is not weakness being
beaten in a battle is not a weakness
it's an opportunity to get back up and
show your strength emotion is strength
you can be badass but be flawed in fact
the actual character flaw she has which
the show does address is how hardened
she has become for her Quest people
aren't supposed to be this hardened
people aren't supposed to go on Revenge
quests like this and be this good at it
if we're talking Star Wars this is the
path to the dark side Mizu is not the
role model of the show that's why we
have Ringo he's the role model with that
knowledge can come growth all of these
elements come together to make a
character I found immensely compelling
even her sword feels like a character
there's an interesting story as to how
she got it how it was forged there's an
absolute feeling of if she loses that
sword how can we go on which again comes
from the love and understanding of the
lore that sword is supposed to be the
soul of a samurai it's supposed to feel
like a part of her and it absolutely
does feel like a part of her I will say
at the very end there was something
unfulfilling about it hate to say it cuz
generally speaking it's otherwise pretty
[__] Flawless just a personal thing
with me I was like you can we're either
GNA set up for season two or this is
going to be
fulfilling we're going into season two
all right but in the end bluee Samurai
incredible binge most enjoyable binge
I've actually had in quite a while as
I'm a night owl at about 2 a.m. I had to
actively consciously think okay I kind
of want to save a couple episodes for
tomorrow I don't want to burn through
the whole thing in a day watching a show
entirely in one day or having to make a
conscious effort to save a little for
tomorrow both are compliments in their
own way I consciously elected to save
the last two episodes for the next day
and I mean that in the best way possible
thank you for the suggestions in the
comment sections I do read your comments
Eight Episodes on Netflix right now
again probably want to wait till the
kids are asleep to watch it there so
bluee Samurai have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see
[Music]
more